these unmanned surface drones make up a
new sensornet already being trialed by
the us navy and the gulf and could prove
a game changer
the net aims to provide total
surveillance of what is going on
under or in the skies over a vast area
of the sea or ocean
here's how it works
the sensornet is made up of more than
100 unmanned surface drones supplemented
by unmanned underwater vehicles and
aerial drones that all form a 3d sensor
grid they're linked to each other and
the headquarters
the vast amount of data sent back is
analyzed by artificial intelligence
software that looks for unusual patterns
of movement
the technology may be mostly american
but the u.s navy is involving its
maritime partners well we think the
equation to to increase our deterrence
overall throughout the region has two
components it's a strengthening the
partnerships throughout the region
component which we're working on quite
vibrantly
the second part then is increasing the
technology and the innovation this is
where the unmanned surface vessels come
on
but the sensor net is in its infancy and
not all the partners on or around the
gulf cooperate in the way they need to
to make the scheme effective problem
that we have here is that the
integration of all these different uh
platforms across the gcc and then with
the americans is is not something that
is feasible because there is absolutely
no data sharing at this point between
gcc navies gcc navies haven't really
integrated it's only integration on
paper and them sharing information is
you know it doesn't seem to be a
feasible thing
regardless of the challenges the
technology allows the us military to
have a far more detailed picture of an
ever increasing area of sea or ocean
right now
the united states navy will be using
aerial sensors like the sky guardian
drone scene behind me but the bulk of
the array will be made up of unmanned
surface and underwater vehicles that
provide all the information giving the
us navy a total surveillance picture of
the gulf and they say this is just the
beginning alex katopoulos al jazeera
doha